hey regal cinemas fans I'm Paul Feig
director of the new Ghostbusters movie
now I'm partnering with IMAX and sony
pictures on a Ghostbusters fan art
contest right now you can submit your
original artwork to imax com / fan art
now the winner will receive a trip to
the Ghostbusters world premiere and the
winning art could be produced as a
collectible ticket distributed in regal
imax theaters opening weekend I'm
looking forward to seeing how creative
you can get be sure to check out
Ghostbusters at imax 3d on july 50
it will haunt you every night whatever
it is no one should have to encounter
that kind of evil except you girls I
think you can handle it oh oh good
thanks we have a gift we see what no one
else is willing to see we do things
others can't do those buses if there's a
paranormal problem we are the ones to
answer the call hello it's the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen what do
we think of these ghostbusters are they
to be taken seriously okay you sweaty
freaks I'm about to say in front ok so I
don't know if it was a race thing or a
lady thing but I'm mad as hell there's a
bigger picture at hand here someone is
creating a device that amplifies
paranormal activity we're gonna need a
bigger boat
hey guys check it out
sounds I was born to be a ghostbuster
right oh man that's so not good
something big is gonna happen the word
we're looking for is apocalypse yeah the
government's trying to claim the event
isn't supernatural we don't want a panic
you don't want miss area and you
especially you John no you gotta yeah no
I'm tired no no I'm just gonna go ahead
and take off how about that I don't
really think that's a good I don't going
to take off don't piss off the ghost
really